hello everybody I hope they are good
we're gonna talk about the weeks okay
because yesterday you watched
yesterday's video we marked these two
weeks we have this week a 28 250 and
then from last week we still have this
target of 27 235 and 27 550 with the
fifty percent of this week okay you can
see the price almost went to this week
but I didn't fill it why because we had
a daily 50ma there check this out
okay check the accuracy
that's exactly if we you know
make a line 27 666 exactly the 50 EMA
you can check in the top left of the
screen twenty seven thousand six hundred
eighty two is the daily 50ma so in in
essence that was the target okay now if
we go again to the one hour time frame
we're gonna go through yesterday's price
action and then I think that we're
probably gonna come to the conclusion
them they might leave this week for
tomorrow okay because tomorrow Wednesday
we have the fomc meeting there is gonna
be a lot of volatility you're gonna see
spikes up and down okay so it's very
likely that you see something crazy like
for example this okay you might see
literally something like this tomorrow
is gonna be very hectic so you have to
keep in mind that if you trade tomorrow
don't trade until probably I would say
after the press conference okay so I
usually when there is fomc I don't like
to trade 30 minutes before the fomc
meeting before the data comes out and 45
minutes after the press conference okay
so that's my that's that's my suggestion
that's what I usually do but of course
no Financial advice you guys can do what
you want you can gamble if you want but
I'm not willing to risk my money okay
now let's go through yesterday's price
action because we have this week okay
and we were talking that if we so you
know
this week getting filled or even a sweep
of the lows so for example we saw here
and price didn't leave an imbalance then
I would enter up a long position and I
did them because if you go to the 15
minutes time frame
I was talking with the guys in telegram
about this you can see that I left this
long week okay so I didn't enter in this
bounce because I was thinking the price
was gonna come back to the zone and you
can see that I did then we have the same
thing going on here another long week
okay in this one
we were expecting the same that price
comes back down to the week so unto here
there is no moment to enter along then
in this Zone okay I like this better
because you can see that doesn't live a
week behind and view to the one or time
frame you can see that this is a bullish
engulfing candle and I entered a
934. so that was around here when I
entered okay so right now I'm in a long
position you know with very tighter stop
loss I don't have big confidence of this
in this trade okay but that was the idea
now what I'm expecting to see today is
if you notice in this Zone we'll have a
resistance okay we've got rejected so
many times so what I would like to say
is something like this okay
if you do something like this then I'm
gonna Target the 50 EMA in the one hour
time frame that right now it's a 28
435. so that's what I'm looking at today
if I say something like this and then
navigation then at this moment I'm gonna
close my lung why should I wait for it
to hit my my entry point again no point
because if I see something like this is
going to come back to the range and
probably it's going to form a range like
this okay until tomorrow so that's what
I'm waiting for yesterday we had a
massive drop I think it was like a four
or five percent it was quite vile let me
check so this was around here
that's a five percent drop so at least
today I would like to see some kind of a
bounce maybe to test the 1 hour 50ma
but again if I don't see that
and I see something like this
then on this moment
I'm gonna get off my long okay I'm gonna
Target this Zone maybe some range and
tomorrow we're gonna see maybe some
crazy volatility and maybe they can fill
the 50 of the week at least okay so
that's what I have in mind at the moment
let's have a quick look at the dollar
Index let's see how it's doing
daily time frame
okay it hasn't lost its lows yet so I
would say that for now the bulletin
makes it safe okay uh remember that we
were talking that this might be forming
a WB pattern okay you can see something
like this may be playing out or this
could be you know push low retrace
continuation so that's the question
right now
before continuation because you know
that Bitcoin trades against the dollar
so if the dollar happens to be forming a
WB pattern and we are now seeing this
leg up then when the dollar Index goes
up Bitcoin goes down okay and this is
crap big distance to me honest this is a
round let me check
almost four percent so that would be
well without the almost because it would
have to go above this this high so it
will be at least five percent I would
say
and that would mean a big drop for
Bitcoin okay skip this in mind let's see
what the audience is doing in my opinion
as long as the dollar Index doesn't lose
this low then I'm gonna be favoring a WB
pattern now if we see the dollar Index
is starting to lose this low of course
yes we're gonna spec lower prices
probably 96. I would say 90 between 96
and 95 would be uh a normal Direction
you're gonna be able to see very clearly
here the inverse correlation between the
Dual index and Bitcoin okay so if you
check the level the orange line is
Bitcoin and what we have in the chart is
standard index okay so you can see
through that index makes a top okay
that's the 8th of March and you can see
the Bitcoin the 10th of March you know
makes a bottom and that's when we start
to see this crazy rune for Bitcoin from
20K all the way to 30k at the same time
that dollar Index went from 105
to a hundred okay so you can see the
correlation there now the drawing is it
seems like it might be formula W
formation is found for now a bottom okay
and you can see the Bitcoin is starting
to retrace okay so if we continue to see
that index going high
then Bitcoin is going to go low okay so
that's what you have to pay attention to
however if we see the opposite and we
see the dollar Index continue falling
then Bitcoin is going to have another
Rune up okay
this is what in my opinion it's very
important to always keep an eye on the
dollar Index because sometimes it can
help you to anticipate the next move for
Bitcoin this is the best example in my
opinion you can see very clearly that
the total index is forming a clear top
here you can see the the Scandal the
dodgy candle and then a very single
thing candle that happens the eighth
what the 9th of March and Bitcoin starts
to go up the 10th of March so here you
would know that the next day the most
likely thing is that the dollar Index
goes down and Bitcoin goes up let's have
a look at the SMP because the SMP is
doing some interesting Moves In This
Zone okay so let's go there
here
okay let's go to the smaller time frame
but lower time frame okay so you can see
that we had but we were in this range
for
quite some time 24 days that's more than
three weeks okay and now finally
seems that it has breaking out of this
of this range the question now is are
you gonna see something similar to what
we saw between the 13th of April and the
20th of April okay that was a deviation
or what we saw in the 25th on 27th of
April another deviation because what the
SMP has to do here is you know retest
this Zone
and then go higher and then we would
Target 4200 okay
because that's around the number it's a
psychological number it's a
psychological song where we could see
rejections okay and some kind of
sideways move in this zone so that's
what I'm keeping a look now because if
we see this in P coming lower and it
fails to test this one as uh support
then we're gonna go back in this range
is that clear
now this gwick is going to be wild for
the SMP don't get me wrong because we
have tomorrow on Wednesday the pharmacy
meeting on Thursday we have Apple's
earnings around on Friday we have the
non-farm payrolls okay so it's gonna be
a very volatile week for the SMP so if
he can hold this Zone that's great
because we're gonna be aiming we're
going to be targeting 4200 but if it
loses this Zone and goes back into the
range then Bitcoin might have an excuse
to continue going down okay so that's
the important thing about the SMP and
Bitcoin that correlation that they seem
to have the fomc meeting tomorrow so
Navi a very interesting one because 25
25 basis points is priced in you know 85
percent of the market is expecting 25
basis points so that's price thing
that's not a problem
I think they think that's going to be
volatile tomorrow is going to be the
press conference let's see what Jerome
Powell has to say
but seeing that the Futures markets
they are pricing three 25 basis points
cuts
this year so basically three rate cuts
of 25 basis points
I think that the most likely thing is
that you don't power comes tomorrow and
says in the press conference
again that there is not gonna be right
Goods this year so let's see how the SMP
takes that okay that's that's what I'm
anticipating for tomorrow's press
conference
it's not gonna be a surprise 25
basis points highs nobody's gonna be
surprised the market is not gonna be
surprised about that that would be
surprised about their press conference
you do high block capital in the three
months time frame
so we have a bigger the bigger picture
of where the liquidity is in higher time
frame you can see there is liquidity
pure emotes in both sides okay we have
liquid to the round so we have loads
at 22 400 and 600 also a 25 400 and 600
this is uh mayor this was a major
resistance in the past
that it hasn't been tested a support yet
so that's an interesting Zone obviously
if we lose 27 000
we're going to be aiming at 25 600 okay
that's the reality but there is also a
lot of liquidity to the website look at
this Thirty one thousand two hundred and
thirty three thousand four hundred so we
can't dismiss the possibility that
Bitcoin could be going higher
okay of course he also depends on the
dollar index in my opinion let's see how
the double bottom develops
now in the one month time frame we'll
have pretty much the same story lots of
liquidity at 26 400 but also to the
upside all the way to 33k there is loads
of liquidity especially between 31 300.
and thirty thousand three hundred
so that's basically between this Heist
that we had for some time how many days
that was for four days
and also the up right above the previous
size because always above previous highs
and Below previous lows there is quite
of liquidity
and in the 70s time frame
let's see what we've got here
I see quality liquidity to the upside at
30 300 okay that's why on the Sunday
update we're projecting first that maybe
they could take this Zone but they
didn't just went all the way low okay so
now we are very close to 27 000.
right below their wig maybe that could
be a sweep of the lows
or it just must be continuing going
lower because there is also quality
liquidity at 26 450. so you can see that
the liquidation hit the maps at the
moment it's not very clear
you know if let's check the six months
time frame because I don't think we've
checked this one
I mean
yes the liquidity the major liquidity is
to the downside 25 500 22 500 18
000 also a lot of liquidity and below
the previous lows because always below
the previous lows there is a lot of
liquidity and that's at 13 500. now I'm
gonna say we're gonna go here because we
are at twenty eight thousand at the
moment okay
and I don't know how the last quarter of
the year is gonna play out I posted the
31st of December that we were expecting
the first quarter of the year
a bear rally then a pivot
in the in the second quarter of the year
we just started the second quarter of
the Year let's see if the FED can pivot
but they're gonna probably say tomorrow
that we're not going to see any rate
Cuts this year and then if they do that
pivot in the second quarter of the year
I said that if that happens
you know looking at what happens
historically after the fat pivots we
could see
a refession and a big dump for the SMP
at the end of the year of course you
know it's difficult to tell because I
don't know what the fat is thinking I
don't know if you know they don't want
to Bluff tomorrow and said they're not
going to do Red Coach and then when I
end up doing them or they actually they
are not going to so let's see how that
develops but if we see you know the
second quarter of the year a pivot
I probably go with a narrative
that we're gonna have a baddest end of
the year
I don't know if you want to go all the
way to the lows it seems pretty far at
the moment where you know that was 15K
we're around almost 30k it's it's a long
distance so again guys level by level
if we lose 27k then 109 for 25.
400 ish what it was the previous
resistance and if we lose that of course
we're gonna look at these liquidations
at 22 500 and so on so guys thank you so
much for watching and I'll see you soon